[Music]
foreign
ER is loving the mom life and reveals
her sweet nickname for her newborn son
come on let's talk about it on Monday
the new Mama gave her 12.3 million
Instagram followers an update on
motherhood with a series of snaps from
her stroll with her baby boy leotis Leo
for short That's the actress smiling
from ear to ear posing in front of the
New York City skyline wearing a brown
jacket blue jeans and Nike sneakers her
little one snug as a bug in the stroller
oh my gosh yes sir yes
in the caption Kiki calls being a mom
her greatest gig of all saying that she
will never be the same again I don't
think there are any words that I can
really Express it's just kind of one of
those things where you're just happy and
elated Kiki says she's learning how to
balance it all and looks forward to
discovering the new person she's
becoming if you thought I was a bad mama
jama before you can't imagine the
greater purpose my son has given my life
your girl is ready for the part but our
favorite thing about this whole post is
the cute nickname she has for her babe
mookie Mook this has been the biggest
blessing Kiki revealed she was expecting
her first child with boyfriend Darius
Jackson back in December while hosting
Saturday Night Live people have been in
my comments saying Kiki's having a baby
Kiki's pregnant and I want to set the
record straight I am
of course those in Kiki's Inner Circle
like Lonnie Love learn to the good news
ahead of time I was like okay you know
Auntie Lottie go be quiet but I just
love
it Kiki and Darius welcome to little
mookie Mook to the world in February and
ever since Kiki's kept it real about
Parenthood when it comes to raising a
kid I've already learned in these short
few days that
it takes a village Kiki shared that
emotional clip just days after giving
birth doubling down in the caption quote
I ain't gonna lie I'm getting cooked I
just want anybody out there that is a
single parent that's been doing this
um friends of mine people that I don't
know family members of mine
I'm really in my in my heart Bring tears
to my eyes
I am just truly
profoundly impressed you have my respect
sister well we just gotta say we're
impressed with you Kiki Mama Hood looks
good on you
[Music]
foreign